I don't know about you but I love a good
sci-fi flick especially when there are
major plot holes in the science part of
the movie and like after re-watching
some classic fan favorites I couldn't
help but compile a list in my head of
all the movie premises that would never
happen in the real world like this
should be a no-brainer but when I first
watched it I was totally convinced that
a T-Rex was going to show up at my door
but according to the Jurassic Park lore
all you need to make that dream a
reality is an ancient mosquito a bit of
dinosaur blood and some frog DNA to fill
genetic gaps I mean I struggled to pass
high school chemistry and biology but my
toxic trait is that I think I could
totally make that happen if there was
actual dinosaur DNA lying around that
survived a hundred million years it's
all an illusion can anybody call up
Target for me and ask if they have some
in the back please remember when I said
I struggled to pass high school
chemistry and biology well you're in
luck because math also wasn't my forte
and I'm about about to give you a little
bit of a lesson so as animals grow
larger their muscles must also grow and
adapt to accommodate their increase in
Mass think about the thick legs of
elephants and dinosaurs gorillas
obviously have no trouble supporting
their own body weight but if you make
them larger like King Kong but then keep
the proportions the same way as they
were before they literally wouldn't even
be able to walk let alone climb the
Empire State Building if King Kong were
real his muscles would be a lot thicker
and bulkier he'd also be way slower it's
just not possible for him to look and
move around like he did in the film so
New York City is often cold but never so
cold that it's completely frozen over
worst case scenario you've got to dig
your car out of a few feet of snow and
might slip on some Icy sidewalks well in
The Day After Tomorrow a climate change
crisis leads to the next ice age after
some majorly unsettling weather
catastrophes and according to a study
done in 2018 that type of change is
pretty much impossible well to happen as
quickly as it did in the movie anyway
and also even if temperatures did drop
that low it would take decades for that
type of climate change to happen the
movie for entertainment purposes of
course dramatizes the speed at which
this type of disaster occurs so Bruce
Willis enters his sci-fi hero era by
landing on an asteroid set to collide
with the Earth and setting off a
hydrogen bomb splitting it in two well
according to experts this logic doesn't
exactly add up a study completed in the
UK by a group of physics students
concluded for that plan to actually work
the bomb would need to be a billion
times stronger than the strongest bomb
ever detonated on Earth I repeat a
billion times stronger also another
perspective on this not knowing that an
asteroid the size of Texas would be
hitting the Earth in less than 20 days
is extremely unlikely you would know way
before that more like years before that
still it's a super fun movie to watch if
you're not afraid of natural disasters
you might actually be surprised about
what I'm going to say about this one
in Will Smith's 2007 box office hit his
character's objective is to create a
vaccine to cure people from a fatal
virus that left him essentially the last
Survivor on Earth the virus ends up
mutating and becoming Airborne infected
people also spread the virus by biting
one another so here's where the facts
get a little muddy viruses don't shift
from one type to another that's just not
how they work at least not outside of
Hollywood anyway again this one should
be a no-brainer but honestly how cool
would it be if you could actually do
this where are you right now
there are a few things that fall into
the realm of never gonna happen when it
comes to Inception number one dreams are
specifically perceived by the person
whose brain activity is going off like
it's just as likely you could insert
yourself into your favorite Netflix show
from the couch as it is to put yourself
into someone's brain waves and another
thing that can easily be debunked about
the movie is there are no medications
that can actually induce REM sleep
regardless of what the label on the
sleeping pill says so yeah in a lot of
ways Inception is top tier fiction but
there are a lot of things Christopher
Nolan did get right though only bending
the rules for our entertainment so
honestly we can't be mad at it so this
next one on the other hand is something
I can be mad at mostly because I'll
never be able to figure out how he did
it Jeff Goldblum also known as the
computer virus Master well in Hollywood
anyway because in real life this would
not go down the way it did no one back
in 1995 and no one now even can figure
out just how he managed to connect the
Alien Invaders computer network to
distribute those viruses like I can
barely figure out how to reset my router
let alone connect to a network in outer
space but what are your theories on how
he made that happen so okay yeah all
these movies are insanely fun to watch
but rank high on the list for improbable
circumstances I mean like it might be
pretty cool to see a King Kong remake
where he's totally jacked and moves
slower than my grandma on her Volkswagen
though but what are some movies that
should have been on this list